there's plenty of evidence that many
smokers use vaping to reduce or quit
smoking in fact adolescent smoking has
continued to fall as adolescent vaping
has increased another anti-vaping
argument is that it has negative mental
or social health consequences studies
like electronic cigarette use and mental
health the Canadian population-based
study suffer from the same issues as
studies linking vaping to Future smoking
it's easy to show that Vapors have more
psychological and social issues than
non-vapors but that's only an
association an obvious alternative
explanation is that troubled kids are
more likely to vape either as a form of
self-medication or because they have
less regard for adult opinion and rules
or perhaps because they are less
supervised or have less to lose by
acting in a deviant way